John Rebecca Kerr from Australia writes
in and by the way her Twitter handle is
at Rebecca acre she was hoping we could
cover how fans and viewers can impact a
story and upon further research we found
that consulting producer Ben Edlund
supernatural has a quote where he says
just as fans respond to the material he
hopes that the material also responds to
the fans like any dialogue were in that
conversation it gives us an indication
of where the viewer expectation is and
that helps us play tension against the
newer expectation we want to scare
people and surprise them and make them
worried so it tells us where the
zeitgeist is moving so we can do the
counter move or move along with it so to
further about this question what do you
think of fans influencing what is seen
on television this is a major change in
the way television works from the way
has worked in the past certainly more
than two decades ago the this is the
popular medium we're dealing with
millions of viewers every week and so
with the presence now of the Internet
the ability of shows to hear from their
viewers especially their religious
viewers and those are the people they're
trying to get to is much greater than it
ever was before and they really like to
get that feedback
I remember remember many years ago when
I worked on the staff of 21 Jump Street
a Stephen Cannell show we would get
occasionally a letter write snail mail
sent to us this is many years ago we get
and and we would we would devour this
information but somebody who cared
enough about the show to write to us and
tell us what they liked and what they
didn't like and so the show creator and
the show staff are very interested in
getting
kind of feedback now it also comes from
the fact that the audience is story
knowledge story ability is much greater
than it ever was before and keep in mind
the great challenge for the SAFF writers
which is how do they stay ahead of their
audience because the audience has seen
all this before thousands of times they
seem that genre before thousands of
times so especially if they're a
religious viewer they are going to spot
story moves episodes ahead and as the
separator that is what you are trying to
avoid at all costs so that is the most
valuable information you're getting when
you get feedback from your audience
because they're going to tell you things
they like about these characters things
they didn't like moves that you use that
they didn't like and so on moves that
were unbelievable and so on it's very
valuable but the most valuable thing
about it is it allows it gives the
writers ammunition for how to fool the
audience because those writers will
never give the audience what they asked
for I would like you to have the caret
character X do this
that's exactly then what they will not
do because again their their their key
requirement is stay ahead of the
audience and that is very difficult
excuse me very difficult to do so
someone like the creator of excuse me
I've seen him on Twitter he'll tweet
back and forth of the fans things like
that so it's good to have a dialogue
going what you're saying don't give them
what they want
trick them in a sense to always keep
them on their toes exactly that's what
they really love but you have to do it
within the parameters of the show within
who those particular characters are and
this is this is the great challenge for
but for the staff because especially as
you move past the first season you get
into this
extendibility how could we keep telling
this story Walking Dead is a perfect
example of this this is a show about
killing zombies okay so you could the
effect of that and the shock of that is
over in the first season so we take this
story to a new level so that it isn't
just a series of beats of zombies attack
we stab them through the eye and then
there's another zombie and we knock
their head off and so on and so forth
that's not story so this is this is what
the great challenge for the writers are
and why the audience can be so helpful
because that is the most advanced people
in the audience are the people who will
actually take the bother to write to the
people on the show going back to your
time on 21 Jump Street so when you would
receive a letter like that how would it
be presented was there staff meeting
you'd all get around and read I think
that you know Johnny Depp shipped of
this in the senior Richard Grieco
whoever how would you present that to
the group would you consider it would in
my memory way where work was typically
the the showrunner would get the letter
would read it and say hey we got this
letter you might want to take a look at
it and everybody wanted to take a look
at it because they these are always fans
I mean it's not somebody writing in
saying that was the worst episode you
ever did I mean it's possible yes it
that they would write that but usually
it's we love your show we love what
you're doing I especially love this and
when this happened in blah blah blah so
I mean that that kind of praise that
kind of feedback just everybody ate that
well because you you're writing on these
shows you're writing in a vacuum you're
your I used to talk about going into the
story minds every day because you would
you would work 12 plus hours a day that
the hours are atrocious on these shows
because you're trying to generate so
much material in such a short period of
time so you were basically in a little
cave with the other members of the staff
and all you did was think and talk about
those stories with those people you
never see your family if you work on a
staff you know you know the other staff
writers better than you know your family
so that that kind of you know
hermetically sealed world you get stuff
from the outside especially from people
appreciate what you're doing and it's
just like manna from heaven
you